[Musique]
merci de nous rejoindre pour cette
nouvelle émission sur tv 78 émission au
cours de laquelle nous allons partager
ensemble la richesse du département
qu'il s'agisse de culture de loisirs de
patrimoine et j'espère que nous allons
vous donner envie de sortir ou de
ressortir de chez vous avec moi
aujourd'hui mélanie poker michael et
demi d'euros bonjour à tous les deux
jours mélanie tout à l'heure vous allez
nous parler de randonnée xiam ou une
première balade pour ce début de saison
tout en douceur on commence lentement
michael côté gastronomie une bonne
adresse aussi à découvrir mais pour
quelques jours malheureusement encore
voilà je vais vous emmener à
clairefontaine dans un restaurant vous
verrez ils étaient plutôt bons et il
éphémère donc il faut se dépêcher d'où
son nom l'éphémère parade tout à l'heure
et vous initierez aussi au simulateur de
conduite en défis que vous vous êtes
lancé avec nikola d'andry régulièrement
nous allons mettre à contribution les
journalistes de la chaîne qui se
lanceront des défis en attendant voici
les autres sujets dont nous allons
parler au cours de la prochaine demi
heure à dampierre et depuis 2020
d'importants travaux de rénovation du
château se déroule son nouveau
propriétaire redonne vie à ce patrimoine
local et vous propose de découvrir le
chantier en coulisses dans quelques
jours saint-quentin-en-yvelines prendra
vie au cours d'un spectacle peut être
ferez vous partie de l' aventure puisque
des amateurs de l'agglomération vont
rejoindre les professionnels ce sera à
la commanderie les répétitions elles
viennent de se dérouler et puis un
nouveau jeu de société qui mêle lettre
mot graphisme vient de voir le jour à
l'initiative d'une yvelinoise moffou
elle développe et donc par une habitante
de voisins-le-bretonneux cela s'adresse
à tous à partir de 10 ans pauline
l'homme sa conceptrice viendra nous le
présenter en plateau il est temps de
débuter cette émission le premier numéro
de 78 tours commence maintenant
et c'est par un hommage que nous en
débutons jean paul belmondo légendes du
septième art s'est éteint mais saviez
vous qu avant de devenir le magnifique
il avait passé une partie de son enfance
dans les yvelines à clairefontaine par
la suite il est aussi revenu dans le
département pour des tournages ou encore
pour le mariage de son ami de toujours
célia engel son dos nous en dit plus
c'est de 1942 à 1944 que le jeune jean
paul belmondo a passé son enfance à
clairefontaine en yvelines son père paul
belmondo avait loué une maison de
campagne au bois joli il craignait
durant la guerre des bombardements à
paris et c'était donc réfugié avec sa
famille à clairefontaine lors de ses
deux années passées dans ce village et
ville est loin jean paul belmondo il ya
fréquenté l'école communale était
également enfants de coeur pour l'église
du village il était revenu sur les lieux
de son enfance il ya quatre ans pour se
rendre au presbytère en 1989 le célèbre
acteur foule aussi le sol yvelinois lors
du mariage de son ami de longue date
jean rochefort à réseau près de
rambouillet il était témoin avec un
autre ami bien connu lui aussi philippe
noiret et concernant sa filmographie qui
compte en tout plus de 90 films sur 50
ans l'acteur a tourné à
carrières-sur-seine le film l'alpagueur
réalisé par philippe labro il y joue le
rôle de hommes d'un certain roger pinard
qui en fait un surnom beaucoup plus
vendeur qui est l'alpagueur et qui va
alpaguer un baron de la drogue après
moult aux aventures
jean paul belmondo et a même été en 1988
au zoo de thoiry pour itinéraire d'un
enfant gâté son partenaire dans le film
richard anconina à jouer une scène avec
une des lions du zoo jean paul belmondo
lui n'a pas tourné là-bas ils étaient
juste venus saluer l'équipe du film lors
de cet hommage
merci célia autour de la table un
souvenir de belmondo un film
particulièrement moi j'aime beaucoup la
hd assange j'en ai vu beaucoup mais avec
ma famille on regarde souvent l'as des
as du coup j'adorais avec les cascades
tout ça c'était c'était parfait moyen
que je vous conseille si ces hold-up
d'alexandre arcady ce temps film franco
canadien on provost si guy marchand jean
pierre marielle après tout aussi un ami
de belmondo depuis toute jeunesse
s'étendent à dernier film où belmondo à
cette image un peu de voyou sympathique
de casse-cou aussi on envoie quelques
images ya même eu une autre adaptation
ensuite américaine de ce film là voilà
un peu un film américain mais française
vous conseille celui-ci voilà je dors je
vais regarder peut-être ce soir on passe
à un tout autre sujet michael vous avez
testé pour nous l'une des bonnes tables
du moment dans les yvelines le
restaurant s'appelle l'éphémère et c'est
à clairefontaine tout à fait où il frôle
imaginez vous en train de déguster des
tapas cuisinés à la plancha sous une
tonnelle dans un parc d'une centaine de
mètres carrés le rêve c'est le concept
imaginé par sylvain et stéphanie ce
couple s'est lancé dans cette aventure
après plusieurs mois de réflexion
c'était le 26 juin dernier se sont
installés à copenhague jusqu'au 26
septembre on écoute sylvain au micro de
tv 78 et une cuisine conviviale
familiale en fait on a voulu faire on
aime beaucoup faire à manger on a
l'habitude de recevoir pas mal de monde
on a voulu en fait que claire comme si
on était à la maison et créer un lieu où
nous on aura envie d'aller et voilà on
peut dire que ces familles là les grands
gagnants la recette a fonctionné à cet
été sylvain et stéphanie et leurs
équipes font jusqu'à 50 couverts par
service milliers soir du jeudi au
dimanche et ils ont réussi à fidéliser
une clientèle venue principalement des
environs de rambouillet on écoute l'une
de leurs plus fidèles clientes
quelque chose de génial c'est très
original et c'est génial les repas sont
vraiment bien et le personnel super
sympa
aussi cette fois à 8 fois je sais pas
souvent et je reviens encore à la
semaine prochaine josiane qui va donner
envie d'aller découvrir ce restaurant et
qui sera sans doute présente aussi pour
les journées du patrimoine 18 19
septembre oui le restaurant va
s'associer à la chapelle de
clairefontaine situé à une dizaine de
mètres le lieu culturel ouvrira ses
portes au public sur le thème gallo
romains avec notamment des conférences
pour l'occasion sylvain et stéphanie
vont proposer en parallèle un grand
banquet gaulois midi et soir pendant les
deux jours on écoute sylvain on va
transformer un peu le restaurant au lieu
de ce que ce soit des tables
individuelles on va faire des gros
banquet
on a un ami cuisinier du quotidien
spécialement pour ça pour s'occuper d'un
menu autour du cochon avec avec par
exemple du comment du porc rôti confié à
l'hydromel donc une bière à base de miel
et puis on fait des tourtes des
tourteaux un peu champêtre façon vos
l'oise avec des champignons de la farce
de porc et puis on dessert ça sera un
gâteau aux marrons non à la noisette
avec une crème de marron ça donne envie
d'y retourner ce week-end en tout cas
ville mais ils avaient rien amené à
commencer la préparation il ya rien à
découvrir c'est ça revient sur la table
mais je me casse ça commence bien alors
le menu entrée plat et dessert sera à 22
euros sans boissons l'éphémère pourrait
recevoir près de 300 personnes sur ce
rendez vous en tout cas wilfried je vous
conseille d'y aller j'ai pu déguster un
plat quand même et c'est délicieux vous
vous avez déguster mais nous on a droit
avec mais malheureusement à 6000 foyers
les ce week-end en tout cas dans le 78
tours nous allons tous les mois vous
donner des bonnes adresses dans le
département nous irons aussi tester des
food truck par exemple si vous avez des
conseils à partager à nous donner
n'hésitez pas à nous les faire suivre
sur nos réseaux sociaux on va parler
culture à présent tout autre sujet de
danse plus précisément avec des
performances inspirées du land art c'est
la chorégraphe joanne leighton qui lance
une série de créations et qui s'appelle
made in c'est à travers toute la france
elle a fait escale à saint quentin en
yvelines il y a eu cinq danseurs et 50
habitants du territoire qui ont répété
ces derniers jours avant une
représentation qui aura lieu pendant les
journées du patrimoine avant une
nouvelle escale ailleurs en france voici
les coulisses
made in c'est un projet participatif
lancé par la chorégraphe joanne leighton
il propose de représenter une ville et
ses habitants à travers un spectacle
adepte des gestes simples des mouvements
de groupe médine sky c'est un projet
participatif qui est proposée par la
scène nationale de saint quentin en
yvelines et la commanderie c'est un
portrait
de la ville un portrait de saint quentin
en yvelines et surtout un portrait de
ses habitants une cinquantaine
d'amateurs et néophytes même du
territoire s'associe aux danseurs
professionnels de la compagnie wld end
et joanne leighton pour va pour créer
une oeuvre à une oeuvre artistique
il ya un regard très professionnel et
toujours avec beaucoup d'humilité et
beaucoup de bienveillance et à dire
qu'on accueille vraiment tout le monde
des gens qui ne sont pas du tout on est
vers de la danse et et on arrive
toujours à un niveau assez
impressionnant comme sylvie ce sont une
cinquantaine d'autres habitants du
territoire qui ont répondu à l'appel
tous amateurs mais aidés de cinq
danseurs ils sont venus faire le
portrait danse et de saint quentin en
yvelines après une trentaine d'heures de
répétitions ils vont se produire la
commanderie c'est vraiment un travail
sur le collectif sur la masse et comment
en oeuvre chacun à l'intérieur pour
travailler collectivement à produire à
produire une oeuvre marche travail sur
le mouvement sur la masse et le
collectif le projet est ouvert à tous
sans critère d'âge et de niveau
l'objectif est que chaque personne
présente travail en communion avec le
groupe il n'y a pas beaucoup
d'individualités dans le spectacle c'est
c'est tout on fait tout en groupe en
fait et ça j'aime bien j'ai pas vraiment
l'habitude de faire ça l'idée c'est de
tisser de tisser des liens de céder des
chemins aussi à l'intérieur de cet
espace de la représentation
et je pense que ça qu'on soit danseur
professionnel ou
ou amateurs
on en a tous besoin la pièce durera en
tout 45 minutes un projet qui s'inscrit
dans une volonté de la commanderie de
créer des projets humains et
collaboratif
l'émission 78 tours premier numéro se
poursuit un numéro de septembre
et dans cette émission nous vous parlons
du patrimoine de la richesse du
département nous parlons aussi des des
personnalités et des créations qui
peuvent avoir lieu dans les yvelines et
là ce sera le cas à présent avec pauline
l'homme bonjour vous n'allez pas danser
dans ce spectacle de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines néanmoins vous
avez développé un nouveau jeu pour faire
travailler un petit peu la tête ça
s'appelle moffou je vous laisse
présenter le petit cube puisque c'est un
ca se présente dans un intense un tout
petit cube voilà face à la caméra ça on
verra c'est aussi simple que ça ça
s'appelle moffou et on manie les mots
avec ça comment ça fonctionne déjà alors
c'est un super jeu apéro qui se jouait
super facilement déjà c'est bien l'ex
sphère valero c'est parfait donc je
propose de montrer des cartes pour
expliciter les règles du jeu par exemple
si on regarde cette carte on doit
trouver une expression
en voiture simone exactement
donc là vous remportez la carte et il ya
trois difficultés au niveau de
difficulté est là c'était la saisine le
haut niveau le plus facile
au niveau intermédiaire a aussi trouvé
enfin c'est quelque chose de licencier
point je suis un point c'est compliqué
cela prend la deuxième carte chez valve
33 je ne sais pas du tout ce sont des
expressions à trouver à chaque fois ou
presque c'est démodé nom d'acteur de
films par exemple à ses quelque chose de
l'histoire ah d'accord j'ai rêvé de
discorde chez le cheval 2 3 exactement
ce qu'il ya 2-3
c'est donc là vous remportez la carte et
à la fin du jeu on compte le nombre
d'entonnoir qui se trouve derrière les
cartes et celui qui en a le plus à
gagner d'accord comment vous est venue
cette idée autour d'un apéro j'en suis
sûr mais pourquoi dans ma famille on
aime beaucoup les digues bats et du coup
j'ai relevé le défi d'en faire un jeu
d'accord et du coup j'ai commencé par
faire un prototype papier que j'ai fait
tester à ma famille et mes amis pendant
les fêtes de fin d'année et en voyant
que la mayonnaise la mayonnaise elle
prenait je me suis vraiment on me dit
que j'allais faire créer le jeu donc
j'ai appris après appelé des designers
des imprimeurs s'est passé pas du tout
votre carrière professionnelle non je
suis dans la chimie je chante études
d'arômes alimentaire d'accord c'est donc
rien à voir à part la création
qui
fait un lien entre les deux est
découvert cette passion pour créer pour
créer ce jeu il ya eu un appel à
financement participatif
ah oui j'ai fait une cagnotte litchi qui
a permis un peu de financer le projet et
sinon oui c'est un bon financement mais
ça prend quand même temps pour créer de
a à z un jeu du coup j'ai commencé en
décembre dernier et à la production a
commencé début juillet donc environ six
mois ce rapide et aujourd'hui on le
trouve où ce jeu moffou à on a un site
internet s'appelle moffou point fr où on
le trouve au prix de 19 euros 90 et on a
aussi une boutique partenaire dans le
nord à lambersart à côté de lille et
bientôt elle sera is le jeu sera
disponible dans la boutique des rires et
des jeux à côté de la gare à montigny et
ont fait une une soirée découverte le
samedi 25 septembre ou ensuite on pourra
venir acheter le jeu dans la boutique
cette boutique dont on avait déjà parlé
sur cette antenne où on peut découvrir
tous les jeux de société et c'est
effectivement depuis la période
confinement les gens se sont re
découvert une passion et moi le premier
pour tous ces jeux en famille et entre
amis aussi maintenant voilà plus ou
moins de succès
on peut commencer à partir de quel âge
sa femme en disant il faut quand même
avoir et on peut jouer entre générations
besoin oui bien sûr simone s'est pas
table à 10 ans donc on transmet bataille
j'ai plusieurs retours par exemple une
grand-mère qui jouait tout seul elle dit
qu'elle joue pour lutter contre
l'alzheimer et un grand père qui joue
avec ses petits-enfants mais seulement
par exemple avec les cartes vertes pour
parce qu'il ya un niveau plus facile est
comme ça il leur apprend les expressions
de la langue française mais une carte en
tout 150 150 par difficulté et avec
simone de personnes du coup qu'ils
peuvent jouer en même temps où j'avais
déjà joué on était quinze coffre à
défier la
rédaction effectivement vous avez prévu
de renouveler le stock de cartes aussi
pour eux pour la suite vous travaillez
déjà sur la suite de ce projet on a plus
de 1000 card avance on peut faire plein
d'extension si le jeu explose donc pour
la distribution du jeu vous avez
travaillé seul ya pas de la maison
d'édition qui s'est mis avec vous c'est
le but aussi peut-être après
développer plus pas forcément tous
édition d'accord tout le temps vous avez
d'autres idées de jeu aussi non ça vous
a donné on s'est juste celui ci s'est
certes et s'il est lancé et ça y est
c'est parti et puis le le mettre à jour
aussi une dernière terre peut-être way
or celle là celui qui gagne remporté la
merci merci merci
et la plus dure la plus difficile
difficile ou qui ont promis difficile
très difficile convois convoi de six
tonnes un niveau qu'il faut avoir
oula
c'est ce qu'on la voit exactement
vrai qu'avec les cartes difficile et
miel désole que vous nous attaquez les
cartes facile voilà 28 mai le souvent
très bien ce jeu développé s'appelle
moffou on redonne la date pour ceux qui
veulent le découvrir le tester
physiquement voir à quoi ils ressemblent
et puis elle essayait entre amis ou en
famille 25 septembre a menti et
bretonneux la boutique s'appelle des
rires et des jeux merci beaucoup pauline
l'homme 90 présenté ce jeu en plateau
maintenant ce n'est pas avec la votre
tête c'est plutôt votre endurance que
nous avons testé michael effectivement
on a pu tester avec nicolas landry mon
collègue
tout simplement simulateur de f1 où vous
allez regarder la séquence en débrief
après
[Musique]
pour ce premier défi de la saison nous
sommes à l'espace de loisirs skywest à
montigny le bretonneux au sein de la
structure et ouais bon jour michael
bonjour nicolas alors pour ce premier
défi une question simple est ce que tu
aimes la vitesse j'adore la vitesse est
rousse regard des allemands il ya des
formules 1 tu es plutôt poids lewis
hamilton fernando alonso a je l'avoué
j'adore lewis hamilton mais je n'ai pas
la prétention de dire que je suis aussi
fort que lui écoute moi c'est plutôt
fernando alonso grand fan des années
2000 parce que c'est là où il a gagné
tous ses titres et des écoutes michael
on va y aller mais avant cela on écoute
tout de suite luca otmane le responsable
du site qui va nous expliquer l'histoire
de ce site les activités et il va nous
annoncer notre défi
highway c'est un complexe de loisirs
multi-activités on va proposer de la
simulation automobile que ce soit des
voitures de rallye ou des voitures de
formule 1 qui sont tout monté sur vérins
sur six axes dont elles vont bouger en
fonction des mouvements du pilote on
propose aussi de l'escem game avec trois
scénarios différents et de la réalité
virtuelle avec cinq missions différentes
vous allez être équipés de la tête aux
pieds comme des pilotes professionnels
vous allez avoir un petit briefing qui
va vous expliquer quand même comment
fonctionne la voiture et ensuite vous
allez être installés dans les voitures
pour effectuer une course avec les cinq
autres participants
mickaël nicolas tous les deux vous allez
vous affronter sur une course de formule
1 vous allez faire trois tours et on va
déterminer qui de vous deux est le plus
rapide
[Musique]
moi sortir remonter dans la monoplace
nicolas je suis en place méfie toi je
suis lewis hamilton doit franchement bon
courage à toi l'âme de frein mondiaux à
londres aux réunions mois bonne course
nicolas
c'est parti
[Musique]
il
mulhouse
dernier tour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et bien voilà on a vu le vainqueur bravo
mickaël qui était bien mathieu quand
même merci beaucoup mais tu étais
vraiment beaucoup plus fort que moi
aujourd'hui je dois m'incliner c'est
comme ça puis les sensations sont
excellentes les sensations sont
excellentes c'est pas facile mais quand
on a compris le système c'est pas mal et
donc y jouer c'est ouvert dont du
mercredi au dimanche les activités je
les rappelle un escape game réalité
virtuelle rallye ou encore la formule 1
comme nous l'avons testé et si vous
souhaitez faire comme nous et tester des
formule 1
c'est environ 50 euros par personne
moi ce que je retiens de cette séquence
c'est la mode estime nicolas dandridge a
fait les tous les modèles c'est toujours
modeste la victoire vraiment il il
apprend la victoire comme il prend la
défaite sans faire trop jamais c'est
vraiment en mesure 1 vous avez tout
toujours je jure effectivement ça donne
permet d'avoir un bel aperçu de la
personnalité des journalistes que vous
voyez tout au long de l'année comment ça
s'est passé parce que vous parlez des
sensations avec nicholas les avez
ressenti ces sensations de vitesse alors
les sensations ont l'air santé alors
pour moi je pense qu'il manquait
peut-être un peu un peu de vent
peut-être pour donner l'impression
vraiment de vitesse mais mais par contre
dans les virages où les accélérations
sens bien ça à tester vraiment ça a
testé mais je pense que ça peut même
aller encore un peu plus loin peut-être
qu'ils vont développer quelque chose de
supplémentaire
et les gens malades en voiture alors moi
j'avoue que je peux être un petit peu
malade en voiture et là je l'étais un
tout petit peu ça passe mais c'est quand
même perturbé on lui au lieu de faire ça
la prochaine fois vous irez faire une
randonnée avec mélanie exactement au
grand r si je précise également
anticiper sur chaque émission et
attendra pour les randonnées mais si à
chaque fois on va choisir nos champions
à chaque fois sur chaque chaque émission
pour la prochaine émission alors moi je
choisis célia gars tsongo pour le défi
du coup le 1 vs 1 du coup ça va être là
la chronique de chaque émission un
contre un chaque émission chaque mois
exactement et nicolas landry m'a donné
son petit papier qui il a choisi je ne
le savais pas avant le début les
missions il a choisi à justine à brasier
et il a rajouté pour sa force sa
ténacité et son au courage où il a son
poulain alors donc du suisse justin et
célia vous voyez tout au long de l'année
que ce soit pour le journal le magazine
culture cette saison pour se défier un
contrat la discipline on va on va la
trouver on ne savait pas encore si vous
avez des idées vous pouvez aussi les
soumettre un combat dans la boue
par exemple je vois que vous avez
apprécié cette blague voilà merci
beaucoup
randonnée à présent avec vous oui moment
il vous propose qu'on commence en tout
ça on va pas on va pas aller à 281 me
conditions climatiques de ces derniers
temps ça va être compliqué mais on part
du côté de magny les hameaux 5,5 km de
balade sur une durée d'à peu près une
heure cinquante c'est la randonnée
trente-et-une de l' ouvrage de la
fédération française de randonnée un
départ fait facilement accessible en
voiture puisque on peut se garer sur le
parking de l'ancienne abbaye de port
royal des champs alors la balade passe
tout près du monument vous pouvez
apercevoir le domaine à travers un mur
effondré ou même plus loin en déviant
légèrement du parcours si vous décidez
de suivre exactement le circuit il y a
seulement six points de passage à
respecter difficile pas trop difficile
pas trop de difficultés sur ce parcours
alors déjà souvent quand on part sans en
donner on a peur de se perdre si comme
moi vous perdez régulièrement là il n'y
a pas d'inquiétude tout au long du
parcours il ya des balisages sur
certaines randonnées les cartes ign sont
un peu complexes elles sont parfois
difficiles à comprendre pas celle ci il
ya aucun souci du point de vue physique
il ya quelques côtes à gravir mais bien
sûr rien de bien compliqué juste à noter
deux franchissements de la d 91 dont le
deuxième peut être un peu périlleux on
peut prendre l'air on peut s'avérer on
peut aussi découvrir ce patrimoine
yvelinois déjà port royal des champs de
ce côté là
l'ouvragé donne quelques points
historiques vous pouvez apprendre
l'histoire de ce site une partie passe
aussi au coeur des deux hameaux de
manille la bien nommée les hameaux bull
loyer et romainville j'ai
personnellement mis à peine plus d'une
heure sans nécessairement marché très
vite mais j'étais tout seul donc on
parle beaucoup moins moi la première
c'est une bonne mise en bouche pour une
famille ou même quelqu'un qui veut
marcher tranquillement ou tester ses
capacités surtout en début de saison
avant de faire des randonnées plus
longue et difficile y en a beaucoup des
randonnées à faire dans ce département
yvelinois il ya un guide pour vous aider
à choisir et à vous y retrouver un petit
peu dit de référence c'est les yvelines
à pied s'étaient dit et par la
fédération française de randonnée que
soutien du département des yvelines il y
à 44 promenades et randonnées référence
et répartis en quatre niveaux de
difficulté de très facile à difficile
entre une heure cinquante de trajet
s'est tenue aujourd'hui pour la plus
facile 7h30 pour la plus difficile et
c'est votre défi pour le prochain numéro
du 78 tours vous irez faire le parcours
le plus difficile oui je vais
m'entraîner d'ici là parce qu'il ya 29
km à parcourir 5 9 très bien ok
effectivement ce sera pour la fin de la
saison dans ces cas-là mais mais promis
vous la ferez
allez vous engager à la faire avant la
fin de la saison on va essayer l'idéal
ce serait peut-être de la ferme en
février mars quand il fait quand même
pas trop chaud c'est quand on avait vu
mes joueurs
parez vous pour février je n'y a pas de
toute façon non mais 7h30 si vous partez
déjà avec un peu de retard à la limite
on danse nous allons bientôt refermée ce
premier numéro de 78 tours auparavant
dernière idée découverte régulièrement
nous allons vous emmener au plus près du
patrimoine yvelinois et pour débuter
cette cette séquence préparé par justine
brasier nous allons aller à dampierre en
yvelines à la découverte du château qui
a été repris il ya quelques temps et le
son nouveau propriétaire même des
travaux d'envergure
[Musique]
je me trouve actuellement au domaine de
dampierre en yves in situ en vallée de
chevreuse ici les parcs et jardins ont
été réalisés par le paysagiste andré le
nôtre ce château du xviie siècle que
vous voyez derrière moi a été réalisé
par jules hardouin mansart l'architecte
du château de versailles on va aller le
découvrir dans quelques instants mais
tout de suite ont rejoint pascal teva le
directeur du domaine détenu par franky
mulliez c'est au cours du 19ème siècle
que il ya une grande restauration qui a
été menée et qui a un peu chamboulé
l'image que jules hardouin mansart
voulait en données puisque l'architecte
du banc qui avaient beaucoup restaurer
les patrimoines en france est bien
intervenu lui-même à dampierre et il a
donc apporté une touche supplémentaire
notamment par des changements parti-pris
de teintes d'enduit et autres
[Musique]
des travaux de restauration débuté en
février 2000 bas et nous on va les
découvrir ce chantier de l'intérieur
quelques niveaux d'échafaudages à monter
et on va arriver sur les toits ou
principalement là il ya les travaux de
couverture et de charpente et bien au
fur et à mesure de les découvrir eh bien
les travaux des maçons des menuisiers
autres koba suivez-moi
là on est complètement dans les
entrailles du château voyez derrière moi
il ya une partie complètement éventré où
on voit les pièces des greniers qui
apparaissent ou alors on voit les
tuyauteries les chauffages avoir donné
et c'est donc tout ça on est dans les
entrailles que les plus complètes c'est
ce qui par contre préserve le bâtiment
parce que ses entrailles ces deux
squelettes du château ce sont les murs
c'est la charpente très peu de
remplacement puisqu'au privilégie une
restauration qui soit qui préserve
l'existant et donc ce fronton et bien on
recolle des petits morceaux ou alors
vraiment on retravaille très finement
sur cet ouvrage
écrit en fait on est dans un bras qui
normalement inaccessibles ah oui oui oui
là là nous évoluons aujourd'hui sur le
chantier à proprement parler
complètement isolée de la visite que
l'on fait avec le public par mesure de
sécurité ou le public évolue lui dans un
site côte mon propre série n'a pas
l'embarras les machines des matériaux
est ici vous voyez vous êtes encore plus
près de l'oeuvre puisque là on a devant
nous cette lucarne qui vient d'être
restaurée on aperçoit les bois neuf les
bois anciens des greffes fin tout était
voilà les compagnons charpentiers
restaure cette lucarne
dans le dessein du xviie siècle sous le
contrôle de la chaîne de notre
architecte en chef des monuments
historiques
[Musique]
vous l'aurez compris l'objectif ici
remplacé les éléments abîmé et préserver
le décor cette partie et n'est pas
accessible au public mais des visites
guidées sont organisées au plus près du
chantier
merci à justin c'est la fin de ce 78
tours émission dédiée en totalité aux
yvelines à ses richesses à celles et
ceux aussi qui font vivre ce département
michael mélanie merci à tous les deux de
m'avoir accompagné pour ce numéro on se
retrouve le mois prochain pour un
nouveau magazine et puis à bien sûr
d'ici là à temps aux nombreuses
émissions à très bientôt
[Musique]